here in New York City this morning the
mayor's announced two more people have
tested positive for the virus many
schools around the world as you know
have shut down some for extended periods
of time as if virus spreads in the u.s.
some schools in seven states have
temporarily closed as a precaution Meg
Oliver's at a middle school in Little
Falls New Jersey without other schools
are preparing for possible outbreaks Meg
how are schools getting ready good
morning to you good morning Gail and yes
let's be clear this middle school behind
me is still open for business but they
say they are prepared for the worst if
they had to shut down they could
continue teaching remotely through the
end of the school year raise your hands
if you're concerned with the coronavirus
at the Middle School in Little Falls New
Jersey there's no panic but there is
concern I'm like I don't want to die I
would like to hear answers about how we
can prevent it viral how I could spread
so quickly is like super dangerous I try
to impress upon them that they're
resilient they're strong that they're
very capable of handling things that are
challenging Shari Glassman is the school
psychologist what do parents need to
know about the coronavirus grown-ups
have to be aware of our own anxiety
children pick up on that they start to
say wow if my mother or father is doing
this then then maybe I there is
something I should worry about is there
an age limit where you wouldn't talk to
a child about the coronavirus I would
say absolutely any child under six I
would not be having a conversation
unless they brought a concern to you
school officials are doing their best to
keep the virus out so students won't
have anything to worry about the
custodial staff is wiping down door
knobs handle bars inside the bathrooms
you've stepped up cleaning absolutely
how many more times are you cleaning now
this time of year we pick up just
because viruses the flu are always more
prevalent in the winter so we'll go from
one or two times a day to then two or
three and now we're up to four if there
is an outbreak are you prepared I
believe we absolutely are the corona
virus has forced several schools in the
u.s. to closed briefly but in countries
like Japan and Italy schools are being
closed for weeks we can hear you can you
hear us in Little Falls they're prepared
to teach kids remotely if the schools
are forced to shut h-has technology to
learn from home how long could you teach
remotely honestly and and I'd be looking
for the teachers to join in if we had to
we could teach the remainder of the year
remotely mrs. Donovan are you prepared
to teach remotely if something happens
of course shuttered schools disrupt
whole families and that can cause a
ripple through the economy
first and foremost somebody has to stay
with the children and so it's probably
going to be a parent any household
budget is going to feel that immediately
so discretionary spending it's not the
roof over your head if it's not the food
if it's not the medicine everything else
goes on hold
school officials say it's a good idea
for families to prepare now just in case
schools close talk to your relatives and
neighbors to come up with a plan to take
care of your children
Gail Meg thank you very much
you